hello and welcome to insight Germany my
guest today is a political analyst and
business consultant who served as an
adviser to the head of the Palestinian
negotiation team back in the 1990s
leading up to the peace talks in Madrid
Akram Baker is american-born of
Palestinian origin he's also writer and
has been widely published in the New
York Times the site and many other
important newspapers and magazines you
might have come across him before as
he's been a guest on a number of DW
programs as an expert on the Middle East
welcome to the program
we do want eventually to talk to you a
bit about it at least but really we want
you to be an expert on yourself and get
your insights about living here in
Germany so I want to start with your
background because to quote your hero
mr. Springsteen born in the USA and an
American passport but a Palestinian at
heart
Palestinian at heart I mean that's
pretty much pretty much correct yeah and
but born in Norfolk Virginia I believe
what type of place is there Norfolk is I
think the largest naval base in North
America if not the world I think it may
be the second largest in the world but
it's where we know that entire Virginia
Beach Norfolk neighborhood funny enough
is that I was born in the same hospital
as Clarence Clemons Bruce Springsteen's
yet another connection there yeah yeah
to the boss but that's where my father
was got his bachelor's and his master's
from Old Dominion University and I
wanted to ask about your parents because
I said of Palestinian or origin where
your parents Palestinian then yes it
further back well it was actually my
great-grandfather who emigrated to the
States and my great grandfather and
great uncles are US veterans fought in
World War two and and my parents were my
parents were cousins
which I said explains a lot my case but
they were the most of their brothers and
sisters were born in New York City and
so they moved to the states when they
were when they were very young and you
sent us some wonderful family fell
actually particularly like this one of
it this is now there's this your mum dad
and siblings my mother my father and my
older sister and my next younger sister
they're actually two more now but they
were born later in Iran the right overs
and I'm on the right with Aramis you
what's behind you is that an
extraordinary wallpaper
it's not a wood no no these were one of
those things in the 70s it was very big
there was a place called all end mills
which was this very large photo shop
chain and you would go and take the
family pictures there and they would put
these backgrounds behind you I so as you
can tell you know we're very very well
dressed according to the 70s with our my
plaid pants and the wide collars yeah
very cool well retro as they say another
photo now with a really nice haircut
I must say and you it's not easy to make
out but there's a cake you're holding in
your hand
now what and there is a significance to
this cake I believe yes this was at my
school right before I think was the last
day of school before we moved with my
family to Palestine and one of my
classmates mother had made a cake for me
and they brought it to the school and it
was kind of a goodbye party for me
before we left the States
yeah this has intrigued me because they
were an American boy of 15 and your
father decided to uproot go to Palestine
what was all that about my parents
apparently I mean back then I didn't
really understand it I can't say I was
happy about moving to Palestine I was
very much an American kid and I being 15
is not I think that's 14 or 15 I write
obviously can't really remember but
that's a tough age to begin with and
then to move to a place which is shall
we say nothing but I didn't understand
what it was anyway but my parents had
always wanted to move back and my father
was a professor of psychology and he
decided he got a position there at the
University and decided to leave I mean
they left a very comfortable you know
middle class upper middle class
existence you know two-car garage and a
pool and in suburbia and Michigan we're
living in Michigan at that time and and
to move to Palestine say well I mean
we'll keep it in the right order of time
but history repeats itself if I may say
so with your own family in a bit but
before that I'd like to know when you
first came to Germany and why moved to
Germany I mean I think the first time I
visited Germany was in 1990 other than
Frankfurt Airport first time I actually
visited was to visit my then-girlfriend
a half palestinian half german young
young woman at that time still a young
woman so that's why I was becoming it's
become my rise yes but and what were
your first impressions of Germany then
from if you I know you were so clouded
by love absolutely but I really the
first place that I visited was Munich
because that's where nobody else from
where she was born and it was all very
new and I thought I think the first
impression was wow this place is clean
Wow it's efficient yeah really the
trains run on time there are clocks
everywhere and this and the beer is
excellent that's about it for the food
wise but the viewer was great those were
my first impression okay okay and and as
I said history kind of repeats itself
your your father and mother did this and
took teenage children to Palestine and
you started your family here with your
lovely wife
and you also went back you you you
actually more than that you left if I
may say so a very good job at a Dana or
Daimler and went to Palestine what why
well I guess you know you have to put
your money where your mouth is and I'd
always been involved for many years in
politics and I always wanted to do
something instead of always complaining
and not doing something I wanted to be
proactive actually we both did and we
decided to take our two young children
at that time hmm my son was born in
Hamburg my daughter it's her birthday
today happy birthday sweetheart it's my
daughter yes men's birthing we moved to
we decided to move back to Palestine to
see how could we do our part in trying
to change the reality on the ground yeah
yeah and and and your children obviously
too young to really comment on it as sad
at that point yeah yeah all right
and you know kids are kids yeah but you
know you're back living in Germany now
and we were I wouldn't go now to a
report about multicultural children
because this city Berlin is getting very
multi lingual and one hopes
multicultural as well let's have a look
at some other examples of families here
whose parents come from different
cultures they share just two of the
languages they share they're how many
languages do you speak
relatively fluently three really well
and they are obviously English you know
during your native yes English is very
much my name in English I speak from
German and Arabic depends that depends
on the subject I guess and and to tell
me about your kids them they're being
brought up multicultural multilingual II
how many languages today I mean they're
they're fluently bilingual English
German and they also speak Arabic they
understand more than they could speak
and how did you actually I should we've
got a nice picture of your family
you [ __ ] oh technology it went to
another photo is it still staying on the
family photo it is this is a family
photo and how did you do with the kids
actually I only spoke with them in
English and my wife only spoke with them
in German and the two older ones who
actually started school there and
Palestine and the youngest one was born
there so they spoke Arabic and the older
ones we didn't write it - and do you
still do they still speak Arabic not as
much as they used to because it's not
it's neither of our mother language is
either it's neither of our hands but
they still do and where do they I'm
wondering what you think of the
education system here
I think Berlin is quite privileged but
how you laugh what do you want no please
have the education I mean the on one
side it's it's it's excellent I mean our
kids go to the Nelson Mandela school
which is a wonderful school and a
bilingual violin will scale there's lots
of them actually right and this I should
- sorry just say it's a state school
this isn't paying you know it's not a
private school that's a state school we
also we very much wanted to send our
kids to state schools and it's a
wonderful education system the prime een
my problem with the German education
system is that they don't have a system
of substitute teachers and very often
when one of the teachers ill or can't
make it the kids just lose their cool
they don't they don't have a class and
then happens often and it's not a
problem with our school it's a problem
with all schools they don't have this
substitute system like we did in the
States
mm-hmm so often you know I find our kids
will come home for it you know two three
hours and then go back to school because
oh the teachers not there or this didn't
happen that's the only thing that I find
quite yeah do you know I find what
strange is this this country has one of
the most extraordinary cultural
Heritage's ever but they don't have
music classes in school it's always
extracurricular or see a lot of the time
lot of schoolwork I think you might your
kids might be at a school where it is in
the class
I mean our school I think the Nelson
Mandela school is something special I
mean it's really a wonderful school with
a wonderful school spirit and they do
have they do have a music department
there and they do have music classes so
it's they're definitely getting that
there are kids are getting their own
musical education
yeah we're cut yeah this is another side
of my guest that will come to a bit
later yes I want to come to our
questionnaire because I was very I was
really intrigued by a lot of the things
you wrote as answers in our
questionnaire we asked about the likes
and dislikes here and first of all I
come to German culinary achievement and
do you remember what you wrote there I
think I laughed you did you wrote ha ha
ha is that because you don't like the
German cuisine no I find German cuisine
is somewhat special it can be good but
it has to be made really really well for
German cuisine to be good unlike Italian
cuisine which is never really that bad
you know you could always eat it pasta
anybody could cook everybody can cook
but German food is extremely extremely
difficult to make well and it's usually
made very badly so no ok but you did you
did however put something down as a
German colony achievement I think this
is intriguing from my cube of doner
kebab is invented here in this city
actually in Berlin and are just the
other day by the way the inventor of the
doner kebab has sadly passed away
Kadir Norman who was a Turkish immigrant
living in Berlin and I should also quite
mention because I don't know what it's
like in America but a doner kebab here
is very different to the one you get in
Britain and in other countries they're
very doing they're here I recommend it
to anybody to try out what's right the
the next one that they really intrigued
me was your favorite German word and
this is an interesting one but seems
vizor do you know how to translate that
I have thought about it and I cannot
find a real translation
for that word and I think even earlier I
used it today with you when we were
speaking English because there is no
jury I don't even know an Arabic word
for it I don't know English word for
yeah well we were intrigued our
production team were intrigued and
actually on DW TV there is a thing
called word of the week and it was
featured recently out just quickly
it says no words can found a learner of
the German language more than but
ceilings visor better known by its
abbreviated form B Z W this word has no
English equivalent you could say but
rather alternatively respectively it
really is difficult to translate we
won't go into it further now because
we're we're not a teaching course but
there's one to think about should you be
learning German good German
characteristic what do you think do you
remember what you put there I think I
put their work ethic and they're honest
and they're honest II put they're very
straightforward about my dad and they're
irritating German characteristic which
we have to have both sides of the coin
absolutely Germans can really be very
annoyingly righteous and in what way and
that they would rather they will spite
their they will cut their nose to spite
their face just to prove that they are
right and everybody is a policeman and
they tell you what's not to do and it
can't get annoying having random people
on the street telling you don't ride
your bicycle on this side of the road or
don't cross at this point yeah yes there
are some annoying we should we should we
should turn the slightly positive now
and say best-kept secrets in Germany oh
good lord
us these records are very tolerant yes
and now that's an iPhone that quite
interesting with why do you say that I
mean as as a an American Palestine you
know as a multicultural person living in
my generation I think
when you look at the older generation
less so I mean I'm stereotype I'm
generalizing here but my my experience
has shown that my generation is I found
them to be incredibly tolerant of other
cultures of other people I'm very
accepting Berlin is is also especially
so but when you look at the younger
generation you find a little bit of less
tolerances which is which is a bit scary
really yes you either have even though
they've adopted a lot of both Western
even Arabic I mean I've heard blonde
kids blonde German a typical German
children using Arabic words in the
street yes and I was a bit surprised and
I asked are you are you Arab and they
were like no I'm saying why do you use
those words like everybody uses them
okay but I found a lot of unfortunately
had some bad experiences with younger
younger teenagers kids in their early
20s with we do okay German why do you
think this is if the older generation is
more tolerant I haven't heard this
before I'm intrigued you know why do you
think that could be I think a lot of it
had to do with the the when East and
West Germany United United three you
know reunified reunify the unification
you had I don't know what twenty thirty
million people were absorbed into the
West and their whole lives changed and
everything about their lives
all of a sudden wasn't there anymore and
I think they hadn't been exposed again
I'm generalizing gum they hadn't been
exposed to a lot of foreign cultures
other than Eastern European cultures and
I think they found that a bit difficult
at times and you think this is moved
over to the rest of the youth of Western
influence
but again this is just a feeling but I
go back to say one of the best hidden
secrets about Germany is that they are
incredibly tolerant people of of others
even if they don't always show it
Germans are you know I always like to
say the French act complex but are very
simple and Germans act simple but are
very complex
mmm diverse intriguing to hear next I
haven't heard that but you you have a
point
anyway you also put down as the coolest
living German the designer details so
let's find out more about the man who
shaped the design of one particular
German company and indeed influenced
modern design perhaps more than anyone
else in the latter half of the 20th
century these household appliances from
the electronics firm Braun are up to 50
years old but they still look amazingly
modern they were designed by dieter
grumps one of Germany's most influential
industrial designers clear elegant lines
colorful knobs and handles over simple
white with very little print gums got
rid of the superfluous with great
success his designs are respected the
world over
a trained architect comes joined the
brown company in the mid-1950s
just a short while later he was managing
his own team that's why not it was a
time in which we wanted to sweep out the
old redo and improve everything that was
our concern at the time his first design
was an overnight success a radiogram
which comes to sign together with a
colleague and Google OTT
whether it's an alarm clock or a heater
as Barone's chief designer plumbers was
responsible for it he helped the firm to
develop an individual style and
modernize its appearance his quality
products made in Germany are in demand
the world over right down to the humble
electric shaver shave so gently at the
neck and yet so close my customers love
it
Tom's received many awards even as a
young man well I think deterrence is
probably one of the most important
industrial designers that we've seen I
mean even today you can see a very huge
enough similarity in modern products in
industrial design running through
compass like Mooji and Apple dieter rams
has also designed furniture for vit so
his open flexible shelving system set
international standards at home dieter
Rams also uses his own designs from a
coffee maker in the kitchen to the
furniture in the living room he designed
it all himself if I were to start over
again today I don't think I'd want to
become a designer I've done enough you
know my motto less is more we need to
decelerate things in every respect I
mean we don't need so much we just need
to do things better
often they stop here in this and Bissell
of Bingham Mountain which is what dieter
Rams his designs are all about he's a
man who's always been ahead of his time
and dieter Arms is my guest
Akram Baker's favorite German person
ready yeah do you actually have any
dieter Rams things in absolutely yeah
absolutely I mean whether it be the
clock or the coffee machine or the the
juicer and you know - if we're really
honest if you'd if you extrapolate that
you don't have Steve Jobs a sense of
design or Apple for that matter without
dieter Rams it was mentioned briefly
there because it's actually actually
looking at the piece you get you think
of it I mean it is there's a lot Apple
can be thankful for from him and I also
think that dieter Rams influence not
only the industrial design of our
consumer goods for me he symbolizes
everything good about a German hotel I'm
a big fan of German hotels of less is
more very simplistic classy elegant
designs
well-run very functional and beautiful
at the same time so I was it sort of
leads to my I have a question here could
he have been anything else other than
German absolutely not maybe Danish but
yeah I like to think that the kind of
sums not very true yeah he said there at
the end he wouldn't he didn't if he
could do it all again he wouldn't want
to be a designer we have too much you've
lived in consumer heaven America or a
consumer help you I was gonna say if I
meant I don't want to class it is that
but kind of the opposite
I mean do you think there is too much
consumers as you as a father of three
children is it a tough one it's it's
incredible I mean it's hot it's horrific
at some point and the amount of freedom
doesn't mean too many choices and
sometimes when you walk into a u.s.
supermarket
the sheer amount of choices you have for
cereal for example or yeah it's too much
it become it becomes a burden and you
find it much better here or just as bad
or it's definitely not as bad definitely
not as bad it's going towards that and
not that I don't like choice I do like
choice it's very important but what I
think if you really want to
differentiate the two if we had to
describe for me mass-produced products
in the States are everywhere badly made
and very inexpensive the moment you want
to have products whether they be food or
furniture or anything else of high
quality the price skyrockets not that
you can't get it but it's incredibly
expensive whereas in Germany you have a
level of quality which I personally I've
traveled a lot in my life I have yet to
see a overall standard of quality that
you find in Germany almost everywhere in
the houses and the cars and the and the
things that they design and they make
that's they're simply well-made and
affordable like organic food if you want
to eat organic food in the States good
Whole Foods with a family you have to be
rich to be able to get in here the gym
is very demanding though of quality and
rightly so yeah yeah no no no but I
think that may be part of the reason
absolutely yeah yeah where America just
want the cheaper prices it's also not
true they also want quality but you know
you don't miss what you don't have and
all Germans of all strata understand
what quality is okay let's solve the
Middle East problem because you are an
expert on this we've already got a few
minutes no you said on quadriga or
another program of ours recently the
whole charade of negotiations
in the Middle East is nothing but a
facade to perpetuate the occupation and
I see nothing coming out of this
that's pretty pessimistic if I may say
so are you that pessimistic for the
future for these negotiations absolutely
because they are nothing but that and
you know the definition of insanity is
doing the same thing over again and
expecting a different result and here we
are
20-some years later doing the same thing
with at some points even the same people
rehashing the same thing and expecting a
different result and it's not gonna
happen so when you were doing it 20
years ago you were a younger man you
were working with Pfizer al husseiny
head of the Palestinian delegation at
the Madrid peace talks were you more
optimistic then absolutely and that's
changed completely because they're doing
the same thing what have they got to do
then well I mean there's in a nutshell
obviously sure I'm not sure it solve the
Middle East problem in a moment the key
to solving the Middle East problem is
ending the Israeli occupation there's no
way around it there's no shortcut around
that unless the Israeli occupation has
ended you will never have peace and the
only ones who have the authority and the
leverage to do that is the United States
along with the EU the then and they need
to they need to tell Israel we do not
accept occupation from anybody and if
you look at it was 20 years ago and look
at it where we are today
there's no land left the settlements
keep are being built at an accelerated
rate I've lost hope and I've lost hope
for that and I think we need to move on
to a different dimension but not I mean
presumably you still believe in
negotiation or no no negotiations not
for the not for the sake of negotiations
you know we say Israel wants
negotiations without a settlement and
the fact is that they love negotiations
because the negotiations are going
nowhere
and at the same time there why is it
perpetuating the occupation because the
settlements keep growing and growing and
growing you have to understand that the
occupation in and of itself is extremely
violent and that needs to end for if we
want to secure the future of Palestinian
children of Israeli children of children
throughout the Middle East they have to
understand that there cannot be an
illegal military occupation there
there's no symmetry here in this this
conflict it's not two sovereign nations
you know arguing over a piece of land
it's Israel the occupier and
Palestinians the occupied I mean I must
say you do criticize the Palestinians as
well I mean you took part in a debate
one of the Doha debates you a few years
back called the palace there but the
debate was called the Palestinians risk
becoming their own worst enemy and you
spoke for the motion if I remember
rightly you won the motion yes and and
and why do you think this is why are the
Palestinians their own worst enemy I
think the Palestinian leadership the
political leadership has failed
miserably and if you look at the
Palestinian Authority I mean for many
years I I've said it needs to be
dissolved it has no use if it's one goal
it was to end the occupation they have
failed at that so what is their purpose
and we need to move past all of this we
need to think beyond these these normal
ways of of thinking and we have to shift
the paradigm and that's what hopefully
we we can do mmm I mean I should mention
- you're not as sort of sitting from a
position here in Germany you were you
did live there with your family as we
mentioned between 2003 and 2007 and then
you got thrown out I believe can you
just briefly tell us what happened there
sure I mean I I just have a US passport
and my my wife also carries an Israeli
passport because her father is a
Palestinian but from the Galilee
which was which is which is Israel and
the Israeli government has never
recognized our marriage because she's
Christian and I'm Muslim and there was a
point in around 2006 where they started
denying Palestinians or Westerners
working within Palestinian areas denying
them entry because I lived as a tourist
I had to keep going and coming in and
outside of the country and it reached
the point where actually my youngest
daughter Ariane the starter was born in
Jerusalem and the Israeli authorities
took my name off of her birth
certificate and changed it to my wife's
maiden name and removed my name from the
the place where it said father of child
mm-hmm and we had to leave Wow
so we moved back to Germany believe it
there for the moment you've learned a
lot about my guest
Akram Baker and his involvement in the
country of his heart
Palestine now in our final report today
you're going to find out I've had a
completely different side of Akram Baker
or should I call him SID soon as a fun
guy I likes it I like I come to
October's my real self but in a way
cities that is very much part of me and
and he's the musical part of me
it was musical love at first sight
we're a path that sounds like the wild
circus and that's who we are
so we're very proud of it and I'm proud
to work with all of them
from the first time I met him it was a
very special thing about this I think
he's a brother in mind for me
justice souter that's where
see this multifaceted individual I see
his musician side not the sort of high
profile
yeah restructure of by excited yeah it's
delightful he's a very energetic and
zealous and passionate man I want to you
you're my over there
take a walk
say the NOFA
I just want you to go
I think SIDS it drives the band really
hard but in a very positive way
he's generally not try to say what he
thinks and just sort of make sure that
the songs are getting in the direction
that he wants them to go so having a
band leader is very important and I
think it plays the role really well
music is a incredibly important part of
my life and I hope it stays that it will
always stay that way and it's it's a
gift
Oh
another side to my guest Akron Baker and
we can't show you a copy of the CD
they're recording there because it
hasn't been released yet but it will be
within a week or so and he's going to
give us two copies signed by all the
band promising here on the late the
latest album a wild circus to give away
so write to us at insite at DW de and
you could be one of the two lucky
winners of the CD some people sometimes
people misunderstand me and think you're
we're gonna send you all the CD but I
hate red we do get rough for a lot of
post and akram I can't give away piles
and piles but um we will have that we
can't show it it's it's it's about to
happen
yeah it's about it's about to happen
we're very proud of the you know the
album it's called cannonball and this is
a bit more than a hobby I believe is it
is I mean you know that you you guys
really want to we're go for it we're
serious you know what we're serious
about it we're going for it you know you
have to you have to live your dreams and
I think my music allows me to do my work
better and my my on the professional
side of my professional side allows me
to do my music better though they're all
intertwined and people often ask me oh
they're different lives and I say no
it's my life and I love them both I can
completely agree with you many of people
who watch the program Rigney now I'm a
bit of MU so myself on listening to the
accents they're actually it seems to be
a very multicultural band would I be
right I heard an Australian accent
definitely yeah the Australian actually
he's the sound engineer oh I'm from the
studio I important but but but the band
is is very multicultural whoops excuse
me yeah the band is very multicultural
we have two Germans both are Berliners
we have
Nilesh is a Brit from an English man
who's both both of his parents are
Indian immigrants and Lukas is the bass
guitar says half German half English
lived in Portugal most of his life so
and me being an American of Palestinian
descent was part Jeremy do you find
their very different views musically
between junetta's sort of very German
view or a very well struck now he's the
sound engineer sorry and a very Indian
English view or very or is it well we
definitely have different influences and
we have different upbringings but why
don't you put all that together hmm and
what comes out is the wild circus and
that's what I think makes the band very
special is we've taken all of these
different backgrounds influences food if
you like Nevis and I like to say we're
the only ones who have a good food but
oh we've got one minute left so I just
want to ask you your son was born in
Hamburg one daughter was born in Munich
the other one in in in Jerusalem as you
mentioned I hope you're on the birth
certificate now do they feel they have a
nationality that's it that's a good
question
we've only got about 45 seconds yes I
think culturally they feel that they are
German Americans American Germans and
their hearts are Palestinian and their
food is Palestinian yeah it's it's
strange you know like all of us
multicultural to children we we our
homes are where we lay our hats and our
homes are with our family and where our
hearts are and is this your home do you
think now is this partly partly us my
heart says no it isn't it isn't okay I
love it when I'm here when I'm gone I
miss it that's a great way to end the
program Akram Baker thank you very much
for being our guest
thank you well thank you for watching do
write in for the CD that doesn't exist
yet but it's gonna be there in sight at
DW de join me again at the same time
next week for another guest on inside
Germany from myself all the crew here in
Berlin thanks for watching and bye bye